so was gibt's hier sonst noch so freaky
42 wann kommen neue Mitglieder in Zero
[Musik]
Projekt hallöchen meine lieben Freunde
und herzlich willkommen zu einer
weiteren Folge survival Games endlich
mal wieder nach ein paar Wochen Monaten
ich weiß nicht wie lange ich das nicht
mehr hochgeladen habe oh oh die Map K
ich gar nicht
die kenne ich ja gar nicht okay soll ich
zuerst zu der Kiste laufen oder
irgendwie in die Mitte DANKE DANKE SCHÖN
Leute ich bin sehr schlecht hier drin
deswegen ich denke ich werde darauf
spekulieren hoffen
da läuft er schon
[Musik]
hin oh man ich ich hab doade den
Brustpanzer noch im Inventar okay also
ich spiel auf GOM
hd.net Games und wir haben hier ich habe
die Map noch nie gespielt ich habe keine
Ahnung wo hier gottverdammte Kisten
sind und ich brauche irgendwelche ah
Kiste ein Brustpanzer das ist schon mal
geil so ich s jetzt erstmal ganz kurz
Sachen und danach habe ich bei
twitter.com/concrafter mal gefragt ob
ich
irgendwelche Fragen an mich hab die ich
dann beantworten soll jetzt in der Folge
da meinten viele dann so ja hier hi das
ganz viele Sachen wurden mir da
geschickt also twitter.com/concraft da
könnt ihr mir folgen da frage ich sehr
sehr oft dann einfach mal ja wollt ihr
dass ich über dies Rede wollt ihr dass
ich über das Rede so nach dem Motto halt
sowas könnt ihr mir da einfach dann paar
Ideen schreiben wenn ihr welche habt und
ich würde sagen wir fangen direkt an mit
der ersten Frage was ist dein
Lieblingsgetränk von XX Mina x33 sie wer
darauf jetzt ein bisschen eingehen ich
habe mich schon so ein bisschen daran
gewöhnt dass die facecam bisschen
umgestellt habe oh da hinten die Leute
sind heftig ausgerüstet
ich nehme einfach mal erstmal alles mit
was ich hier irgendwie finden kann was
ist besser steinax oder holsschwert
steinax oder Holzschwert steinax oder
Holzschwert da sind zwei Leute das ist
nicht so
geil Steinaxt oder
Holzschwert ich würde jetzt grob sagen
Holzschwert sind die ausgerüstet nee der
eine ist nicht ausgerüstet okay der eine
wird aber auch gerade
geboxt okay der hat heftige der der hat
eine krasse Rüstung und irgendwas aus
Eisen hat er
auch Bo mein ganzes Inventar ist voll
und ich glaube die Map ist relativ klein
also was hat die gefragt die Mina
Lieblingsgetränk mein Lieblingsgetränk
die haben alle so krasse Sachen da mein
Lieblingsgetränk ist eigentlich also
jetzt auf Energy Drinks bezogen würde
ich sagen ist mein
Lieblingsgetränk ich dachte komm jetzt
hier rein oha aber da laufen gerade
richtig viele her auf Energy Drinks
bezogen ist mein Lieblingsgetränk
Monster dieses
orange oh das war
doof ja das war doof
oh aber da draußen ist gerade mega
Terror habe ich keinen
Kopfschutz doch die schüzt doch
mehr ja gut habe ich
Pfeile nee ich habe keine Pfeile auf
Energy Drinks bezogen ist mein
Lieblingsgetränk dieses orangene von
Monster ich lauf den jetzt einfach mal
hinterher Set di verdammte
TNT jung Lauf da doch mal nein
Mensch aber so allgemein würde ich sagen
mein Lieblingsgetränk ist eigentlich
Fanta weil Fanta finde ich mE lecker
Fanta ist ich weiß nicht mag Fanta oha
der hat heftige Rüstung wow oha der hat
heftige Sachen wie soll ich den denn
umbringen warte ich los den zu soem
anderen oder gehen die jetzt beide
hinter mir her nee die kämpfen sich
beide gegeneinander okay jetzt geh ich
damit drauf wenn einer tot
ist da ich mein
Taktik du bist Kacke oh ein
Eisenschwert so liegt da noch bessere
Sachen ein Eisenhelm ich bra noch eine
geile Hose das ist eine geile
[Musik]
Hose so ich habe komplett eisenrüstung
Eisenschwert da sind noch Pfeile die
könnte ich auch noch
mitnehmen und Bogen habe ich jetzt auch
so sonst ja Fanta ist eigentlich ganz
gut so was gibt's hier sonst noch so
freaky 42 wann kommen neue Mitglieder in
Zero
Projekt theoretisch sind erstmal neue
Mitglieder also ich ich bin ja nicht der
Macher vom Hero Projekt das gehört ja
das Hero Projekt gehört ja mehr oder
weniger Simon werfbarer Trank der
Heilung das auch ganz nice ne könn ich
da so mitnehmen so goldene Apfel auch
besser leben hier
deathmch beginnt schon oha ich dachte
ich könnte jetzt hier so ein
bisschen
hallo es sind neue Mitglieder geplant es
gibt so eine so eine so eine
Liste es gibt so eine Liste wo so ein
paar Leute drauf stehen da stehen glaube
ich Spark steht da drauf no steht da
drauf
ja was denn sonst außer Kampf und da
stehen halt sehr sehr viele Leute
drauf und die kommen halt nach der Zeit
rein wenn eventuell Leute rausgehen oder
wird es eventuell glaube ich bald habe
ich bei Simon
gehört ein neues Projekt geben aber auch
nur
vielleicht
ja okay ich habe
gewannen so also es gibt eine Liste mit
Mitgliedern die noch dazu stoßen sollen
da stehen glaube ich GLP drauf da steht
wie gesagt Spark NOB so ein paar Leute
die halt auch dazu gehören
können und die halt auch mit da rein
sollen wenn halt Leute austreten oder
irgendwie sowas und sonst ich würde mal
sagen ich einfach noch mal wo anders Ruf
damit wir so ein bisschen quatschen
einfach kennen ähm und sonst äh sind
erstmal halt von der Menge das glaube
ich bleibt das so also drei Städte mit
sieben Mitgliedern ist ja schon relativ
viel am Anfang sollten s noch weniger
werden aber sonst bleibt das erstmal so
von den Leuten die da drauf sind so
warte ich muss mich eben
uminen mich unbenannt was WD hier denn
sonst noch so geschrieben
ähm was war dein Traumberuf als Kind und
warum von kein Plan und so äh ja lieber
Mann Frau kein Plan und so mein
Traumberuf damals als Kind war
es was war denn mein Traumberuf ich
hatte eigentlich nie so einen richtigen
Traumberuf alle meinten immer so ja ich
wäre ja so gern irgendwie Astronaut und
so also was ich immer gern machen wollte
war irgendwas mit Fußball das fand ich
immer mega cool also irgendwie Sport
oder so das als Hobby der Skin ist cool
das als Hobby oder so das war irgendwie
weiß nicht das fand ich immer ganz
cool und
ja irgendwie so
Fußballmanager woll ich werden Trainer
oder so weil ich habe mir so gedacht so
ja so Teams einstellen und so da hat ich
richtig Bock drauf also ja so
[Musik]
Fußballtrainer steht hier sonst noch so
warum schlafen alle Youtuber so komisch
also so spät es ist doch egal ob man in
der Nacht oder am Tag schläft von
lufandy ja
also ich kann das ja selbst sagen ich
schlafe eigentlich nicht komisch ich
mein Körper ist nur irgendwie so da
eingestellt dass ich richtig
richtig viel Schlaf immer benötige also
bei mir ist es so ich schlafe in der
Schulzeit gehe ich immer so um um 11 Uhr
ins Bett aber dann bin ich
um ich würde sagen um oha der da der hat
ein Schwert der Pisser nee der hat eine
Spitzhacke okay dachte der wä mit einem
sch her in der Schulzeit gehe ich immer
so um 11 Uhr zwar ins Bett aber das das
heißt ja nicht dass ich dann direkt um
11 Uhr schlafe sondern ich bin dann
meistens erst so um 12 Uhr wirklich am
schlafen weil ich
dann ich gehe mal lieber der ins gebüch
vielleicht sieht mich da keiner
m weil ich dann noch am Handy bin oder
halt weiß ich nicht ich brauche auch
immer sehr sehr lange bis ich überhaupt
mal eingeschlafen bin das ist auch mal
so ein bisschen ärgerlich bei mir ich
kann nicht einfach so im Bett liegen an
einem normalen Schultag kann ich nicht
so im Bett liegen und einfach dann mir
selbst zu sagen okay in 10 Minuten bin
ich eingeschlafen oder so ich brauche
locker immer eine halbe Stunde wenn ich
nicht müde bin wenn ich müde bin ist das
klar dann kann ich schon falle dann kann
ich schon relativ schnell einschlafen
oder wenn ich besoffen bin dann bin ich
innerhalb von 20 Sekunden bin ich dann
eingepennt
aber sonst so nö kann ich nicht
eigentlich kann nicht so gut einschlafen
aber sonst mein schlafritmus ist
eigentlich gar nicht mal so gestört
sondern nur die Zeit in den ich immer so
schlafen gehe also ach das ist doch zu
erklären also ich gehe in der Schulzeit
habe ich immer so 6 Stunden schlafen das
halt viel zu wenig deswegen denke ich
mir dann immer so ach am Wochenende
gleichst du das eh wieder aus weil
Wochenende dies da bisschen länger
schlafen und so aber denkst weil am
Wochenende ich habe mir mal eingebildet
so am Wochenende hole ich das auf bilde
ich mir auch immer noch ein aber am
Wochenende bin ich dann halt immer
feiern und dies das Ananas machen Ananas
und das ist halt dann immer so ein
bisschen doof mit dem nachholen wenn man
dann am Wochen Ende selbst sogar noch
weniger schläft als in der Woche weil
z.B jetzt Samstag also
vorgestern war ich um 5 Uhr um um 4 Uhr
zu Hause um 5 Uhr war ich dann am pennen
weil ich mir noch Waffeln gemacht habe
weiß nicht war besoffen
und dann irgendwie habe ich glaube ich
bis 11 Uhr gepennt weil ich dann dachte
oh nein ich muss noch Hero Rändern und
da ich wollte noch mit dem Kumpel was
machen und alles dann war ich dann
irgendwie um 11 Uhr schon
wach ne ne
ach nö ach nö das ist jetzt nicht hier
so
ein was mache ich denn jetzt kann ich
hier
raus
oh ja
jo Schleck mal so kann ich irgendwie
runter ohne mega Schaden zu nehmen
au
ja und ich habe mir dann halt immer so
eingebildet ja am Wochenende holst es
nach aber Wochenende kann man das nicht
nachholen dann habe ich halt jetzt auch
wieder am wochenendeur 6 Stunden
geschlafen und das ist halt so die Sache
es ist jetzt nicht so bei mir dass
ich du Pisser du tötest mich
eh der hat heftiges Equipment
junge okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay
[Musik]
forest okay ist
irgendjemand okay
jetzt und dann nicht
wie ist das so
ja es ist 3 Uhr aber ich bin noch nicht
müde so nach dem Motto sondern bei mir
ist das so
es ist zwar 3 Uhr aber ich kann noch
nicht schlafen gehen weil man dann
irgendwie noch auf einer Party ist oder
weil m
oder ich kann nicht schlafen weil ich da
noch Hausaufgaben machen muss oder so
z.B gerade ist Sonntag abend 20:40 Uhr
und ich muss noch Englisch Eva Aufgaben
machen Eva eigenverantwortliches
Arbeiten nicht dass sie denkt so was Eva
heißt Lukas Lehrerin etwa Eva dürfen die
sich da dzen nee also das ist so
eigenverantwortliches Arbeiten
und ja das ist es halt ich bin einfach
ein
nicht beschäftigter Mensch aber
so ich ich ich ich verplane mein Leben
komplett falsch ich sag's mal so was
sagt ihr zu dem Justin Bieber Drama
Drama
Queen ja ich verstehe nicht was mit dem
Jungen los ist Alter also natürlich er
wird von allen möglichen Leuten unter
Druck gesetzt und so habe ich eine
bessere Ausrüstung als der da hinten ich
glaube nicht aber wenn ich vielleicht
von hinten an i ranehe jetzt hat mein
Hals gerade irgendwie Geräusche gemacht
wenn ich vielleicht dann hinten von
hinten an ranehe kriege ich den
vielleicht oder machen die Team Bo bitte
Box euch
Jungs ja die Boxen
sich
auf den hinteren kann ich locker drauf
gehen den schaffe ich locker dann habe
ich ein steinschwert und dann schaffe
ich auch den
vorderen was war noch mal die Frage ja
Justin Bieber ich weiß nicht was mit dem
los ist also keine Ahnung ich kenne ih
nur so von damals wo der so lieber
netter Junge war da war der mir ohne
Witz sympathischer als dass mir jetzt
ist das jetzt weil jetzt ist irgendwie
weiß nicht jetzt ist der irgendwie mega
komisch ich spekuliere jetzt einfach mal
darauf dass die hier lang
laufen und lauf er mal gegen
Bäume
oh J tun sie jetzt Boxen die sich
da und schon wieder so so ein Schachzug
B leben das ist echt
chillig ich noch tollen Helm hier
irgendwie besseren Helm nee habe ich
auch nicht so aber ich habe ein Bogen
das ganz
schön so die ganze Scheiße brauche ich
nicht liegt da noch irgendwas was ich
brauche n
[Musik]
bisschen was zu fressen zwei Steaks habe
ich nur zwei Steaks
was aber ich möchte doch ein bisschen
mehr Saks haben okay okay dann suche ich
jetzt mal wo ein paar andere Leute sind
vielleicht dann gucke ich mal ob da wer
ist Blitz
[Musik]
hallo ja ich weiß nicht also ich ich
will mich dazu nicht äußern das ist
nicht meine Sache es ist seine Sache was
in seiner Freizeit macht aber wenn
natürlich ich kann es auch ohne Witz
verstehen wenn man da Drogen nimmt in
der Situation weil der ist so unter
Druck unter Druck gesetzt von den ganzen
von der Presse von den Medien das ist
echt nicht mehr normal bei dem aber dann
damit muss man sich quasi
auseinandersetzen und das muss man
bedenken wenn man
ähm in der Position ist und wenn man er
hat geschuft um in den Position zu
kommen äh wenn man halt so
au Superstar werden will so nach dem
Motto dann ist es halt so und vor allem
ich finde der er hatte auch so von
Anfang an viel zu jung viel zu viel
Druck Bo ich da ob steht ein Typ ist da
hinten
einer so schauen wir mal
weiter Döner oder Pizza
Döner Meinung zu asi TV haben wir ja
schon mal ein Hero besprochen also ich
habe das ja mit Max besprochen mit
kranrafter wenn nicht schaut euch an
wenn ihr es nicht gesehen habt das war
irgendwie Folge boah 8283 oder so
irgendwie so um den
Dreh und zwar haben wir da über
Dschungelcamp und DSDS
gelabert
ich bin kein bogenskiller das müsst
bedenken ich kann gar nichts mit dem
Bogen dasmch
beginnt so erstm in eben töten jetzt den
da
vorne oha oha meine Maus lagt meine Maus
me
okay erstmal
chillen chill
runterzählen
gleich geh in deine
Ecke
ja so die erste Frage wenn er aufnimmt
dann Box ich den jetzt
tot
cool okay
also wollen
wir
sagen du hast di Schwert
ne Scheiße hat ein di Schwert
oha hätte ich mir auch ein craften
können nein ich h mir knochenschwert
craften
können ja gut meine
oh nein lass drin der soll das nicht
wegschmeißen kämpf damit hier ist immer
eins drin
oh wusste ich nicht ich muss den eben
kurz so lang auf die Folter spannen eben
schon so lange auf die fter spannen nee
dsungelcamp und as TV und DSDS halt ich
gar nichts von ist auch alles nur
gestellt finde ich das mag ich nicht
so wie erlebt ihr die jetzige Phase wo
EUR und andere Channels sich so von
anderen krass abheben na ja ich finde
eigentlich gar nicht dass unsere
Channels sich krass abheben ich finde
nur dass Minecraft bzw Hero einfach so
mega he
weil sehr viele Leute gucken Hero an und
deswegen na ja wow wow ich hau er mal
hier alles
um oha ich bin gleich tot jeden Moment
oha ich bin je Moment
tot nein da kann ich drüber
springen
oha ich habe ihn getötet das war
fresh na ja
gut was habt ihr noch so für Projekte
vor ja zur Zeit läuft der Hero und
deswegen frage ich jetzt mal so an euch
was wollt ihr denn noch öfter sehen
wollt ihr sowas öfter sehen also das war
sehr sehr crazy weil ich einfach
irgendein Video hochladen wollte wo ich
ein bisschen auf eure Kommentare eingehe
aber kommt drauf an was ihr noch so
alles sehen wollt habt ihr Haustiere und
wenn ja welche also ich bleibbe jetzt
einfach noch ganz kurz hier in der Lobby
stehen
und beantwortet noch so ein paar Sachen
eben so ein bisschen ganz wizig
gewesen ich hatte mal zwei Kaninchen die
sind aber eins ist g dann haben wir das
andere weggegeben
[Musik]
konntet ihr auswählen in welche Stadt
ihr geht hä ich bin halt in der Stadt wo
ich geboren wurde also was soll ich da
auswählen also ich werde wahrscheinlich
nachher nach disseldorf gehen und da
studieren aber ja wie sind wir auf
unsere Youtube namenekommen Bo da bin
ich schon dae ich schon 1us mal drüber
geredet warum heißt du laserla auf
Instagram
instagram.com/laserla nicht concrafter
instagram.com/ccrafter ist in Faker der
ist weiß nicht ich würde nie auch bei
Skype ich würde nie sowas schreiben wie
ja schick mir paysf Karten kommt ein
Hero sowas würde ich nie
schreiben
so ja Laser Laca weiß nicht ich fand
irgendwie ich wollte dieses LL so
concrafter Laser Laca so Doppel
Buchstaben finde ich irgendwie ganz cool
guck mal die laufen mir alle hinterher
ist das witzig das ist cool mal jetzt
kommen die hier lang und dann wenn ich
jetzt einmal diese Druckplatte
benutze jetzt kommen die und jetzt mach
GLE einfach so ein Schutzschild an hier
auf dem
Server verpisst
[Musik]
euch
wieder ich Puste alle weg P alle weg du
kommst auch weg du auch alle weg hier
alle weg hier alle weg hier alle weg gut
wir nehmen noch zwei
Fragen wie findet ihr den Winter ja habe
ich ja den Kontak hochgeladen wo ich
durch den Wald spazieren gegangen bin
wenn ihr es nicht gesehen habt könnt ihr
es ja auf meinem Kanal wieder angucken
m war echt mega witzig eigentlich von
ich ihr ihr habt's ja auch ganz schön
gefeiert dass ich einfach so spontan
aufgenommen hab
m ich find den Winter eigentlich ganz
geil jeder ich finde jede Sommer
Jahreszeit irgendwie geil das habe ich
auch schon mal irgendwann gesagt und
zwar finde ich so Herbst ist so geil so
um einfach so zu Hause zu sitzen Winter
ist geil da kann man richtig gut
spazieren gehen und Schneeballschlachten
machen im Sommer einfach Party Strand
mer sowas und Frühling weiß ich nicht
Frühling halte ich eigentlich nicht so
viel von Frühling muss nicht sein das
ist so die Vorbereitung auf den auf den
Sommer Sommer ist eigentlich so am
geilsten finde
ich regt euch auch die Sache auf dass
alle bei Hero Krieg wollen aber wenn Ihr
Lieblings Let's Player stirbt Weinen
alle rum also ich ich verstehe das auch
nicht weil dass die ganzen Zuschauer
immer so mein Hero sein PvP Projekt Hero
ist ein RPG Projekt lernt den
Unterschied verdammte Kacke RPG heißt
roleplay Game deswegen heißt es Hero
hexit roleplay jetzt heißt ja nicht Hex
VP also Hex also dann he
heb so so heißt es ja nicht es heißt ja
row streng genommen ist das eh ja groß
sogar weil es Hex roleplay heißt
Abkürzung
also ich weiß nicht halt davon relativ
wenig dass die ganzen Leute irgendwie
immer meinen so ja da ihr müsst mal
Krieg machen und sowas alles das finde
ich irgendwie jetzt nicht so geil W
Alter sieht irgendwie krass aus find ich
jetzt nicht so geil weil ich bin ein
Mensch der nicht so gerne Krieg macht in
solchen Projekten ich ma dann lieber
irgendwie dass ich so ne nach demte ja
komm lass zusammen aufnehmen bisschen
chillig chillen dies das bisschen hier
paar Witze reißen und so so wie mit dena
und is jetzt heute und gestern das finde
ich so cool und da möchte ich jetzt
nicht so die ganze Zeit Krieg haben und
sowas alles jetzt nehme ich doch schon
wieder mehr
fragen was hältst du von Kindern die 12
Jahre alt S und rauchen das das regt
mich so auf ich dazu eigentlich gar
nichts mehr sagen das ist einfach nur
abfuck ich weiß nicht solche Leute oder
auch 14-Jährige die dann oder 13-jährige
die dann schon Shisha rauchen oder so
ich verstehe es nicht Leute ihr macht
euch damit alles kaputt das ist kacke
Shisha okay das kann man noch googelen
das ist nicht so schlimm jetzt W also
Shisha an sich ist so schlimm wie
Rauchen aber tut man jetzt auch nicht
jeden Tag so wie
Rauchen aber sonst das ist doch ich weiß
nicht ich halt davon gar nichts ich
Leute die Kinder sind ja noch Kinder 13
14jährig bis 16 ist man für mich noch
ein Kind da ist es halt so dass weiß ich
nicht ich habe vor solchen Leuten noch
einfach keinen Respekt und möchte mit
solchen Leuten noch nichts zu tun haben
also ich finde das auch nicht cool dann
werdet ihr an dem Projekt nach Hero
wieder mitmachen ich weiß gar nicht
gibt's neues Projekt danach ich hab das
gehört von Simon aber sonst noch nichts
ja wahrscheinlich schon es wird ja
wahrscheinlich eh jeder aus Hero
mitmachen komm mal nach Düsseldorf ja
studiere ich
bald was denkt ihr ist nachdem man
stirbt da habe ich schon mal drüber
geredet
würdest du jemals fschim springen ja ist
ein sehr sehr großer Traum von mir was
ist du im Moment am
liebsten was ich am liebsten esse zur
Zeit
ist so Hähnchen Curry mit Reis und so
geilen Früchten auf welchen Festivals
Konzerten wart ihr schon ich war bisher
auf gar
keinem ja ich war bisher auf gar keinem
Festival oder Konzert aber ich werde zu
tomorrow Land fahren
wahrscheinlich wir haben da so eine
Website entdeckt wo man so auf jeden
Fall Karten bekommt oh wir sind bei 25
Minuten noch eine was ist euer
Lieblingsspiel minecraft ist mein
Lieblingsspiel weil Minecraft so immens
vielseitig ist also jetzt auf PC bezogen
ist Minecraft weil ich nichts anderes
auf de PC Spiele auch da auf jeden Fall
Minecraft weil man da so viele Sachen
machen kann sonst würde ich auch nicht
Minecraft
machen sonst was ist denn sonst mein
Lieblingsspiel dann habe ich noch als
Lieblingsspiel FIFA auf der Playstation
3 und ja dann mag ich auch noch ganz
ganz gern GTA V aber das spiele ich
jetzt nicht so häufig
weil der Hype der ist ein bisschen weg
jetzt und ich möchte das auch nicht mehr
so oft spielen aber es war auf jeden
Fall ein richtig gutes Spiel sonst meine
Lieblingsspiele auf der Playstation sind
eigentlich watch dogs watch dogs sehr
cool und FIFA und kenurismo 6 mit
Lenkrad und ja dann würde ich sagen
meine lieben Freunde das war's jetzt mit
dem Video und
ähm die schreiben alle concraftter ihr
lügt doch concrafter ist gar nicht hier
nee Freunde das war's mit dem Video wenn
es euch gefallen hat lasst bitte eine
Bewertung da wenn ihr überhaupt noch
dran seid und sonst wollt ihr öfter
sowas sehen dann folgt mir auf Twitter
und schreibt mir das bei Twitter und
folgt mir auf instagram.com/lerla wenn
ihr Bock dran habt und sonst packen wir
2000 Daumen hoch das wäre schon mega
nice und mein Tisch geschlagen tschüss
und wunderschöne Zeit in der Schule
diese Woche da bin ich nämlich auch